we're learning first details of
president biden's upcoming one and a
half trillion dollar plan to help
american families the president's press
secretary says a large tax
increase targeting the rich could be
part of the proposal
his view is that that should be on the
backs that can be on the backs
of the wealthiest americans who can
afford it and
corporations and businesses who can
afford it
ed o'keefe is at the white house ed
what's the american family plan
all about good morning anthony good to
see you coming into focus here at the
white house is the plans for so-called
human infrastructure the stock market
slipped about 300 points on word that
the white house is working on proposals
to boost
child care for national paid family
leave free community college and
pre-kindergarten classes plus tax
credits to fight poverty
the president is expected to propose
paying for all of this by raising the
capital gains tax for wealthy americans
that's the tax paid when people sell
pricey assets like stocks or real estate
for americans earning more than a
million dollars that tax rate could
jump emphasis on the could to 39.6
percent nearly double what it is now
but as with most of his ideas the
president will face an uphill battle
with congress republicans already
opposed the high cost of mr biden's
other proposals and they're now saying
they don't like this new idea either
because the tax increase could punish
americans for investing
in local businesses or stunt future
economic growth white house age stress
this is all still being workshopped and
coming together the president likely to
begin talking about it next week
and it's also likely to be a big part of
his first address to a joint session of
congress
next wednesday night republicans have
chosen who's going to formally respond
to the president's speech
south carolina senator tim scott is the
choice
a bit of a bridge builder and a party
still trying to sort out what exactly it
is and for
in the post-trump era but michelle also
notable he is currently working with
democrats on some pretty meaty proposals
to address police reform wow huge
talking points there ed thank you